since i cannot
fathom a muslim apologist who is willing
to stoop
to the level of hijab's disgusting
spitfest
spectacles just as my video on muslims
arguing with themselves has proven true
in multiple ways so has my video on
muhammad hijab's
obscene obnoxious behavior
some of muhammad hijab's recent comments
were collected
if you go but look my goodness what is
this
oh look at that oh my goodness look i
don't know if you guys can see this
it's a little light there oh look at
that sir al fatiha
you guys see sir al fatiha here
[Applause]
do you really do you really think
do you really think we can't we can't
escalate do you
my goodness
do you really think
[Applause]
that you want to go this route
do you think oh he he may he made
islamicized me
he made the boom boom room dude i will
buy the domain piss on the koran.com if
you keep going down this road
and every single thing every single
thing that happens
every single thing that happens i always
say this is because this is
this is muhammad hijab he's putting us
in this direction
hey muhammad you like to you like to
spit right
there being any significant challenge to
him
like doesn't he call out any of these
people
uh i'm i'm not i'm not aware of
there being any significant uh challenge
to him
from from muslim apologists or muslim
scholars
uh i'm i'm not i'm not aware of
there being any significant challenge to
him
from